you were asked point blank to denounce
white supremacy
i denounced white supremacy okay you
didn't announce
white supremacy for years but you always
do it you always start off with the
question you didn't ask joe biden
whether or not he denounces antifa
let me ask you about q anon it is this
theory that uh democrats are
a satanic pedophile ring and that you
are the savior of that now can you just
once and for all state that that is
completely not true
in its entirety i know nothing about q
anon
i just talked i know very little you
told me but what you tell me doesn't
necessarily make it fact i hate to say
that i know nothing about it i do know
they are very much
against uh pedophilia they fight it very
hard
but i know nothing about it believe it
or
not
run by the dc subject i'll tell you what
i do know about
i know about antifa and i know about the
radical left and i know how violent they
are and how vicious they are
do you have any remaining symptoms from
kovitz nothing whatsoever i'm
great i feel good in particular did you
have pneumonia
well i'll tell you what happened i
didn't feel good i didn't feel strong
i had a little bit of a temperature the
doctors at the white house are fantastic
as you can imagine and
they really didn't want to take a chance
and they said let's go to the hospital
i said that's okay i'm gonna you know
respond to what you say
you also are a leader in a setter of an
example and if you're not wearing a mask
when your administration is saying best
practice right now is wear a mask no
it's not foolproof but many people are
catching it
many people are getting this disease
that was sent to us by china and it
shouldn't have been allowed to happen
but many people are getting this and i
mean nobody's being blamed everybody is
working hard to get this thing out of
our country
get it out of the world look at what's
going on in europe massive spikes
they've done a very good job but now you
take a look today at the uk you take a
look at spain and france and italy
there's tremendous spanx but our death
rate is worse
than well not spain but those other
countries i have things right here that
will tell you
exactly the opposite me so the uk is up
2
500 because i knew you'd be doing this i
know you very well
the uk is up 2 500
the eu's up 722 percent and the united
states is down
21 but we have per our deaths per capita
is among the highest industrialization
excess mortality we're a winner
taxes as you know the new york times has
obtained it says
years of your tax returns among other
things it says that you have debts of
approximately 421 million dollars that
you have personally
guaranteed and that will come due in the
next four years
the question is on behalf of voters who
do you owe 421 million dollars
what they did is illegal number one also
the numbers are all wrong with the
numbers they released
and just so you understand when you have
a lot of real estate i have real estate
you know a lot of it okay right down the
road doral
big stuff great stuff i'm very under
when i
decided to run i'm very under levered
fortunately but i'm very under levered i
have a very very small percentage of
debt compared
in fact some of it i did as favors to
institutions that wanted to loan me
money
400 million dollars compared to the
assets that i have
all of these great properties all over
the world and frankly
the bank of america building in san
francisco i don't love what's happening
to san francisco
right it sounds like you're saying 400
million dollars isn't that much biggest
office building
but are you are you are you confirming
that yes you do owe
some 400 million what i'm saying is that
it's a tiny percentage of my net worth